[music]
Alexey Navalny
has been doing lately this has already gone far
beyond just this specific
problem of fighting corruption this is no longer a
fight against exclusively corruption this is a
fight just for basic human
values a fight for life he wi
l and bruce jenner hanks asks for the wheez
r he started  you take futures for
strength and the upper hand over birch
we them on and he believes that describe
the chef bolts wet transitional
he is the
main sponsor and did not look forward to 7 cm intex for
and bakugan yes im fritz vat in the league furnace you
yourself call for legs employ here is a record
selling
all these  the persecution is a
continuation of such a response to the
political activities of alexei
navalny as a
fighter against corruption criticism of the regime
criticism personally antique action vladimir
putin
in general there women are infantile
flowers daffodils stu we will he and
mr stop clinton graced our
end it became the leading
opposition  organizations because
if you're talking about
auto corruption  it becomes mathematically oppositionists
because in power in the
presidential administration at the presidential level at the
level of the ruling party corruption is
normal it’s not something that requires
some kind of condemnation of the
communities intense speaking to float
valentina varnavskaya epub personal
reaching Zaitseva shoes festivities late
great canon I’ll do media angel
and
crying mommy mommy feed for
young ladies
on the wave and gadget but moscow
setting it up his massage about
justice aventyl communities bolted on
extra dirt on it is all lives of
protests given st games your party in
power tried to
stain us
teachings today and we see
completely new methods of pressure on people with
different views this is the list of
foreign agents this is the list of
undesirable organizations of
such
data.
fish in zombies professionally styled details
is a prisoner of conscience
should be
immediately released cases
against him should be dropped
new cases should not be started a person
is in prison for his
political activity for criticizing the
ruling regime the
element will be scored nissan titan
timmons price of freedom is out in  the
kitchen in his fight the movies man
5 cars flu
damien rice
than you here scales of white lies people
use him helen m factory this nation
fish simple
mam and robin yulin shooter no smoke no entourage
oligarch
great evil eggs kinder mixture pure
steam farmland want miles  I'm
all aum and is not be hit
em
our main task is the task of the opposition
to continue to tell the truth to convey
information to make information tires and
more accessible to the Russian society